we're going to begin of course with the
raging wildfires in the west they are
still continuing where the death toll
has increased
dramatically overnight nearly 100 major
fires are burning across 11 states
think about this california oregon and
washington are hit
the hardest firestorms have led to mass
evacuations including
more than half a million people in
oregon nearly 12 percent of the state's
population
entire towns have been laid waste now
rescuers in california
have discovered seven more bodies
bringing the overall death toll in the
west
to 16. carter evans is outside a burned
fire station
in berry creek california north of
sacramento carter good morning
well good morning anthony and this
really gives you an idea of how
incredibly fast this fire moved this
fire station was burned to the ground
the fire truck still
inside now this particular fire is
responsible for killing at least 10
people
and 16 are still missing
the unstoppable explosion of wildfires
continues to tear across the west
in california six of the largest
wildfires ever have occurred this year
with more than 3 million acres burned
it's been really difficult
in oregon flames have scorched more than
900 thousand acres in a 72 hour period
that's nearly double the amount that
typically burns in the state
in a year it's unimaginable in
washington dawn marie baxter's sister
jamie hyland was
camping with her husband jake and son
uriel in a remote section of the state
where there was no cell service
the couple couldn't escape the flames of
the cold springs fire in their truck so
they ran
over a mile in the dark to a river
jacob was carrying at least a five
gallon bucket of water and
baby uriel and shielding him with his
whole body in fact his
burns are less because he was covering
the baby and hunched down over him
so low by the time rescuers arrived
uriel had died
his second birthday would have been next
month how long were they
on the shore it was probably over 48
hours so they survived out there for 48
hours
yeah i don't know at what point yuri
passed there was so much smoke i don't
even know how they're alive
the couple suffered third degree burns
and were airlifted in critical condition
to a hospital
where doctors told jamie she had also
lost
her unborn child in my worst dreams i
couldn't imagine what my sister and
brother-in-law had to go through and to
do everything they could to fight for
their lives and to protect their child
and still to lose him and her baby it's
there's no words and nothing will ever
make it right
still baxter has faith the couple will
keep fighting to survive
i'm hoping and praying through their
pain they will be able to come out
strong and help other people who
suffered because that's the type of
people they are
a couple has a very long road to
recovery by the way
another fire crew was overrun by this
particular fire they had to deploy their
fire shelters while the fire went over
them
this is the second time that's happened
in just one month it's normally
an extremely rare occurrence fortunately
there were only two minor injuries
but it gives you an idea of how erratic
and unpredictable this fire is
tony boy carter it's a very tough story
with that family
just harrowing stuff thank you very much